okay another random sub
um opening request list wait
where are my pieces i guess i i can't
play any of these openings
if i'm missing all my pieces but that's
okay this is 3-0
at least i can castle both ways let's do
this
hello eric happy to watch your stream
live
it's 2 p.m in france oh that's a nice
time
happy that you're here but i'm kind of
sad that i don't have any
my like important pieces but the
opponent's not here
so what to do alexa set a timer for
20 seconds 20 seconds
starting now okay
time is ticking ooh okay alexa never
mind
okay canceling your time uh what to do
this is really bad
i can't even fiance
i'll play the the carol khan i guess i
don't know
this is really bad i just have to
i have to be sneaky i have to avoid
all trades like rooks are useless
until the end game
hmm play a6
oh and my opponent's name is tall magnus
that's terrifying hmm
what to play
i am trying to think of some like clever
strategy that i just have to
guess i just have to play somewhat
quickly
hmm
i'll leave the king in the center
ah i just lost both castling rights i
probably shouldn't have done that
that's a good move play this move
now this pawn is going to be a massive
headache
okay closing things down
at least there's some file action
rooks can maybe in the future double up
okay double ups beginning
i'm gonna push all the pawns ooh that's
a
that's probably a good move
let's keep pushing pawns
okay white gamuting some material
but i'm kind of in big trouble here
or am i i probably am
oh so sneaky if i take here there's
takes i have to take with king
so i won both of my center pawns
but it's not really going to help
or is it let's keep pushing pawns
da my pawn
okay at least oh i have one pawn left
the future queen maybe
but the king the king has to be
sheltered by the rooks
that's actually a really good move
that's a really good move
ah my rook
is this a draw i think this is a draw
now
right the king's stalemated
if it takes its stalemate
otherwise i'll just keep checking
draw
clean oh oh i missed i missed my chance
to claim a draw but that's okay
the checks never end if here i check
i'm envisioning like some potential
mates but
okay i'll play rook f1 only legal move
is to take and stalemate me
gg haha okay
i was only hope it was to to run out of
all my moves and draw
a nishkiri would be proud
okay i i survived against the tall
magnus
yeah so it was very important like it
was very important to push the pawn
and then like and then get a situation
where i could stack everything
it worked out beautifully yeah so rook
takes g8 this is white's only mistake of
the game
outside of this movie played really well
just making sure rook takes
g8 draw okay i will probably go on
youtube
um youtube people
hope you enjoyed that this is why you
should never resign
especially when you have a rook because
all you have to do is get your king in
a stalemate position and then kamikaze
the rook
and this is how you can survive like so
many
hopelessly lost positions
so uh twitch chat is saying hi to
youtube
youtube people say hi to twitch chat
sometimes they get lonely so you have to
you have to say hi to them in the
comments
before can't seem to create a game or
sound
all good though that's too bad
anyway if you're watching on youtube
follow on twitch youtube bits
and then you can you can participate in
this madness
thanks bicycle